Okay, I think we should get started.
So my name is Arul Chinnaiyan, and I'm from the University of Michigan, and I'll
serve as chair of this session.
The title
of our session is "From Molecular Mechanisms to
Therapeutic Opportunity in Prostate Cancer."
And so as many of you know, prostate cancer has really served as a
paradigm for precision oncology with really decades of molecular
characterization revealing recurrent genetic, epigenetic, and
transcriptional dependencies that drive disease initiation, progression,
and therapeutic resistance. So in this mini
symposium, we'll integrate foundational molecular
insights with emerging therapeutic strategies to highlight
how mechanistic understanding is being translated
into new clinical opportunities across the spectrum of
prostate cancer states.
So I'm going to open up the session with a little bit of an overview of key
molecular alterations that drive prostate cancer development with a
heavy focus on prostate adenocarcinoma, the
most common form of the disease. But in this session, we'll also
cover progression to neuroendocrine disease.
So to give you a sense of what lies ahead,
I enlisted a bit of help from AI,
which sort of shaped the title slide for this session,
as you can see here.
It also took the liberty
of rendering myself and my fellow speakers as cartoon sketches.
I would say an interpretation
that in Johan's and my case may be rather generous.
So these are the three talks that we'll cover here.
But just to move on in terms of a little bit of a
background. Again, AI assisted here in terms of what I might
cover in terms of oncogenic drivers of prostate cancer, or at
least AI's interpretation of what I might cover.
So for this group, I don't really have to go into a background in terms of prostate
cancer. All of you are likely certainly plugged into prostate
cancer in general, but it's certainly a disease
of older males. And just one point to make is
that when prostate cancer is clinically localized, it tends to have a good
prognosis, certainly a very good prognosis.
But once it metastasizes, generally the prognosis is
poor.
Much of the work in terms of our understanding and therapeutic targeting of
prostate cancer really builds upon the foundational work of Charles Huggins, who
received the Nobel Prize in 1966 and really discovered
that androgens or testosterone are important for prostate cancer
growth, but more importantly, that it could be therapeutically
targeted.
Our work segues into that quite well in that a majority of
prostate cancers hijack the
androgen
regulated enhancer elements
of genes such as TEMPRAS2 to drive overexpression
of ETS transcription factors or oncogenic transcription factors
in the context of prostate cancer epithelia.
And so this ends up being the most common molecular basis
for initiating prostate cancer progression, this
idea of hijacking androgen regulated enhancer or
enhance some machineries of androgen
receptor.
And so there's been tremendous interest in the field in terms of direct
targeting of AR, in terms of as part of the AR neo-enhancer
zone, but also indirect targeting of key epigenetic
factors, other transcription factors, and co-regulators of the
general enhancer zone complex.
So in terms of prostate cancer, it is certainly the exemplar of an oncogenic
transcription factor-driven malignancy.
In terms of European prostate cancers, perhaps 50%
are caused by
gene fusions of ERG.
Another 10% are other ETS transcription factors, and
perhaps another 10% are driven by mutations in the
pioneer transcription factor, FOXA1.
And these are mutually exclusive molecular subsets of the
disease.
So I'm sure that you've all have seen this sort of progression map to
metastatic progression of prostate cancer, where you
essentially begin with clinically localized disease, often treated
with local therapy such as radiation or prostatectomy, and PSA as
a marker of disease burden. Certainly, the PSA can drop, but in some
cases, PSA comes back,
and essentially the disease is recurrent
and then treated with androgen deprivation treatments or
anti-androgens. Then subsequently, the disease can, in
some cases, progress to castration-resistant prostate cancer,
for which oftentimes novel therapies can be considered in terms of
chemotherapy, anti-androgens, and so forth.
So in terms of a historical perspective, in terms of the genomics of prostate
cancer in general, I would say that in the
cytogenetics era, we had the observation or
discovery of androgen receptor alterations in prostate cancer or
APEX loss, NKX3.1 being
important in prostate cancer.
We've had, during that era, really discovery of p53, Rb,
PTEN, and MYC amplification in terms of prostate cancer.
In the microarray Sanger era, Sanger sequencing era, we had the discovery of the
recurrent ETS gene fusions.
And then in the next generation sequencing era, we then had a slew of novel
observations around non-ETS gene fusions, a number of
mutations like SPOCK, FOXA1, IDH1, as well as DNA
repair
genes were identified as being important in terms of prostate
cancer development.So now just to classify the oncogenic
drivers of prostate cancer, we have first the truncal driver alterations.
So these are generally clonal alterations that initiate the
disease, including ETS fusions, FOXA1, ESPL
mutations, and some rare fusions.
We then have DNA repair alterations that can occur, including
homologous recombination deficiency in terms of BRCA1 and BRCA2, ATM,
mismatch repair genes,
as well as biallelic loss of CDK12.
These generally can occur concurrently with truncal driver
alterations.
In terms of alterations that occur due
to therapy, in terms of androgen deprivation therapies in general, we have, of
course, alterations in AR, AR amplifications, AR mutation,
and pathway alterations. And in terms of alterations that occur due
to prostate cancer progression, and aggressive forms of the disease, we have
sort of biallelic loss of PTEN and the PTEN pathway in general,
p53, Rb, and alterations in the MYC
locus.
So with that, I'd like to welcome,
or actually, I think I'm the next speaker. I think I'm speaking next here.
So if we can fire up
the slide deck here.
Thank you.
So what I'll be covering today is this idea
around heterobifunctional reprogramming of androgen receptor
complexes in prostate cancer. I would just say this is a very
hot area
in terms of drug development, this idea of
these bifunctional compounds altering
perhaps protein complexes in the
cell.
Just a few disclosures I need to mention here.
So heterobifunctional molecules in general, I think perhaps began
with the PROTACs,
proteolysis targeting chimeras, where you essentially have a
ligand that you essentially have a protein of interest, a linker region,
and an E3 ligase ligand that then hooks up to the ubiquitin proteasomal degradation
machinery. And so you can design these heterobifunctional molecules to
degrade proteins of interest, perhaps exemplified by the AR
PROTAC degrader developed by Arvinas.
And much of the pioneering work in this space was done by Ray Deshaies and Craig
Crews.
Likewise, other groups, including Nathaniel Gray and Jerry Crabtree,
have had this idea around chemical inducers of proximity, and one
example being the transcriptional chemical inducers of proximity, where you
essentially bring an activation domain of one protein in close
proximity to a transcription factor and turn on that
transcription factor to perhaps induce apoptosis in a cell type.
For example, the BCL6 CDK9 compound.
Likewise, we have the RIP Tags for regulated induced proximity targeting
chimeras, where you can have basically a lineage
specific target, like AR,
and you bring in close proximity an
essential effector protein to induce apoptosis in those
cells specifically. And one example of that being the AR BRD4
compound developed by Halda.
What I'll be focusing on will be this sort of novel class of heterobifunctional
molecules that we call DALTACs or domain alteration chimeras.
So I think I showed you this slide earlier and this general idea that
transcription factors function in these neo-enhancer zone complexes
and that these targets have been therapeutically targeted, perhaps
direct targeting of AR being the most successful thus far.
But there's tremendous interest in really targeting other components of the
neo-enhancer zone complexes, including epigenetic regulators and
even transcription elongation kinases.
But what I'll be focusing on is this idea around targeting
p300. That's a component of the AR
neo-enhancer zone.
So p300 is a histone acetyltransferase, or a HAT,
that is central to androgen receptor mediated signaling.
It has a paralog called CBP,
and they both function in regulating transcriptional coactivation.
p300 is a major dependency in AR positive prostate
cancer relative to CBP, and this is looking at the broad
DepMap assessment. You can see p300 here in terms of dependency
relative to CBP.
p300 and CBP are the only histone acetyltransferases
that acetylate the N-terminal H2B histone tail.
So this is a histone octamer here, and we're talking about these acetylation
marks in the H2B tail that both p300 and
CBP are the only HAT enzymes
that hit these acetylation marks
at enhancer sites. p300 is a coactivator of
AR and physically interacts with androgen receptor.
So in one of our published studies, we've shown that when we look at
a survey of histone post-translational marks, we find that the
N-terminal H2B histone acetylation marks are
significantly elevated in prostate cancer relative
to other histone marks that we surveyed, and this can be visually
appreciated here when we look at immunofluorescence of malignant epithelia, the
green fluorescence relative to benign.
And with this particular mark, and then again, blue
fluorescence here relative to benign.
This is malignant versus benign, looking at this particular N-terminal H2B mark.
So these marks are markedly elevated in prostate cancer
versus benign epithelia.
There's been tremendous interest in terms of targeting this pathway,
in terms of the development of p300 CBP bromodomain
reader inhibitors, some of which I've listed in this table here.
Johan Debono has certainly led a number of these studies,
and this happens to be his preclinical studies looking at Cellcentrix
p300 CBP inhibitor across two different
preclinical models. This study, I believe, has been paused,
perhaps due to tolerability issues, but certainly there's been excitement
around targeting p300 CBP
in general with bromodomain based reader
inhibitors.So we've been exploring this pathway
initially in the context of heterobifunctional molecules in
terms of PROTAC degraders, and this has been in close collaboration with Xiaoming
Wang's group, where basically you have a bromodomain inhibitor ligand, a linker
region, and an E3 ligase ligand, again, linking to the ubiquitin
proteasomal degradation machinery.
So these molecules specifically and selectively degrade
p300 and CBP.
And so this is, again, published work, so I will just summarize this with this
particular slide here, where we basically characterized that
the histone H2B acetylated marks that I've been talking about are
elevated in prostate cancer, but end up being biomarkers
for identifying patients that might be sensitive or cancer
types that might be sensitive to p300CBP
inhibition or degradation. And we also go into some of the
mechanistic details distinguishing degradation of
p300CBP versus bromodomain inhibition of
p300CBP.
So the next question really is that when we sort of pursued this was,
can we find a way with a single bifunctional molecule, can we create
a combination therapy that could target AR as well
as p300? Two components of the
AR neo-enhancer zone. So that's how we sort of started this project.
And so taking advantage of some of the seminal work that the late
Bert O'Malley carried out in terms of the structure of
the ARp300SRC3 complex. And this is
early cryo-EM work where he showed the AR dimer
physically interacts with p300 and SRC3 to
regulate transcriptional activation.
So the question is: Can we impact this endogenous
protein-protein interaction?
So to do this, we developed a series of compounds, and this is,
again, in collaboration with Xiaoming Wang's lab and led by a
talented
chemist, Jianzhang Yang, who generated over
200 different compounds. But essentially creating
these heterobifunctionals where you have an AR ligand, a linker region,
and a p300CBP ligand
as these heterobifunctional compounds.
And I would say that although he generated over 200
compounds, a very small percentage of these compounds ended up actually
having the functional effects that I'll be conveying in the
next few slides.
And to show that this compound was actually hitting the target of
interest in cells, we took advantage of cellular thermal shift assays and
showing that, for example, p300 is stabilized with increasing
temperature, CBP is stabilized, as well as
AR in the context of nanomolar levels of the DELTAC,
while other targets like BRD4 are unaffected.
So again, suggesting that these compounds are indeed binding in cells
their targets that we intended.
Now, in order to characterize the functional effects of these inhibitors, this work
was led by Jie Luo in the group. And he showed
essentially that these are very potent nanomolar or
picomolar level compounds, and you can see effects in
terms of AR-positive prostate cancer cells shown here in red are
basically the DELTACs at a nanomolar or even picomolar
level, quite potent.
And this is probably starkly shown here with 22RV1 cells, which is again an
AR-positive prostate cancer cell line.
You can see at a 10 nanomolar level of the DELTAC, we essentially
extinguish these cells in the context of a crystal violet
assay. While this is not the case with just using the p300
inhibitor and the AR inhibitor. So we're certainly getting
some novel effects with this bifunctional compound.
And what's interesting is that these effects are exquisitely specific to
AR-positive cell lines shown here.
In AR negative cell lines, such as this neuroblastoma cell line, which continues to
maintain sensitivity to p300CBP inhibition, the
DELTAC has no effect, shown in red here.
Now, to extend this further, Jie sort of looked at a larger panel
of cell lines. You can see that in AR positive prostate cancer cells,
these have very low nanomolar level IC50 shown with the red
bars here. These are AR positive prostate cancer cells.
When he extended this across a panel of cell lines, most normal cell
lines shown in gray are unaffected or very high
IC50s, and AR negative prostate cancer cell lines shown in light
blue, also quite resistant to the
DELTAC. So this is exquisitely specific to AR
positive prostate cancer cell lines.
Now to sort of look at the activities individually of AR and
p300CBP. Here we're showing that the DELTAC
is a very potent inhibitor of p300CBP activity in terms
of its extinguishing this N-terminal H2B mark
shown here.
Likewise, when we look at androgen receptor, this is gene set enrichment.
Androgen target genes are markedly inhibited, shown here, and then
graphically shown in this matrix plot.
These are AR target genes, and then with nanomolar levels of the
DELTAC, they're essentially markedly
attenuated.
Now to demonstrate that a ternary complex actually exists between
AR, DELTAC, and p300, Jie took advantage
of the proximity ligation assay, essentially taking two different
antibodies. And if a ternary complex forms,
this assay then lights up in terms of fluorescence, in terms of a rolling circle
amplification of fluorescence. And you can see here
endogenous AR and p300 in vehicle-treated cells.
We see
a small amount of foci formation shown here with the red
dots.But when we hit the cells with nanomolar levels of the
DELTAC, then we see this marked increase of these
red foci representing, again, increased induced
proximity in the context of the DELTAC.
To look at this in an orthogonal way, we took advantage of a series of
immunoprecipitation assays where Jia essentially pulled
down
p300 and then western blotted for AR.
You can see that the DELTAC certainly induces this interaction, in
fact, sort of gluing AR and p300 together.
This was also seen by IP mass spec analysis, where essentially when we
pull down
p300, the top hit was AR, shown here.
And when we do this in a reciprocal fashion, when we pull down AR,
we can immunoblot for p300 in the context of the DELTAC.
When we pull down AR and carry out mass spec-based analyses, the
top hits are p300 and CBP.
To look at this at a genome-wide scale, we took advantage of ChIP-seq
assessments. What we observed was that in terms of AR
chromatin immunoprecipitation, these are the top AR binding
sites and enhancer sites. When we hit the cells with,
again, nanomolar levels of the DELTAC, we're seeing increased recruitment of
AR to chromatin.
But perhaps the most surprising aspect was that similarly, we're seeing
increased recruitment of p300 to wherever AR was
in terms of chromatin binding. So it appears that the
DELTAC is really gluing AR and p300 together.
We came up with this particular model
in terms of explaining the effects that we were observing,
this idea around domain alteration chimeras.
So these complexes form an endogenous
complex of p300 and AR.
In the context of the DELTAC, the domain-domain interactions get
reprogrammed, whereby the bromodomain
of p300 then interacts directly with the ligand binding domain
of AR, then creating essentially these
inert neomorphic complexes that
essentially potentially lose activity.
So to examine this in further detail, we looked at the AR-ERG
neo-enhancersome in general. You can see, as I mentioned, AR
binding is increased. Interestingly, FOXA1 is not displaced from
chromatin, while ERG as an oncogenic transcription factor in the context
of VCAP cells is modestly displaced.
p300, as I mentioned earlier, is essentially glued to wherever AR is.
BRD4 is markedly diminished. Pol II is
diminished,
as well as the N-terminal histone marks that I mentioned earlier are completely
extinguished in the context of the DELTAC.
So then this brings us to this idea around the DELTAC really
reprogramming the AR cistrome.
And again, this is AR ChIP-seq analyses.
We looked at the sites that were depleted with the DELTAC, shown here.
And when we look at the sites
where AR is depleted, they're enriched for these oncogenic
FOXA1-AR half sites that are, again, characteristic of
where AR binds in the context of malignancy.
When we look at sites that are enhanced by the
DELTAC shown here in terms of AR, we see an enhancement
of AR binding to palindromic ARE sites.
So this is the sites that AR binds to in terms of controlling differentiation,
proliferation, and other normal effects.
As I mentioned earlier, we're talking about a histone acetyltransferase.
So we then carried out mass spec-based
histone acetylation analyses. And what we observed
in this unbiased analysis was that the sites that
p300 normally acetylates, these N-terminal H2B
sites, are markedly diminished with the DELTAC.
But interestingly, we're getting an increase of acetylation at
novel sites in the context of proteins that are part of this neo-enhancersome
complex, including the N-terminal domain of AR and SRC-2
and SRC-3. So these are neomorphic effects caused by the DELTAC
itself.
So then we have this general model where we basically have the histone
acetyltransferase domain interacting essentially with the
N-terminal H2B histones. In the context of the DELTAC,
this gets repositioned to interact with the N-terminal domain of AR
as well as SRC-3. When we look at components of the
neo-enhancersome in general, FOXA1, BRD4, and ERG,
we see that ERG and BRD4 are displaced while the pioneer
transcription factor FOXA1 remains.
And we see this enrichment of palindromic ARE sites
relative to the chimeric AR half sites that are associated
essentially with malignancy, essentially sites where AR likes to
bind in the context of malignancy.
So what does this look like in preclinical models?
This is again a series of human prostate cancer organoids.
We saw that the DELTAC was quite potent in AR-positive
patient-derived xenograft organoids shown here.
While in AR-negative prostate cancer suspension cells,
these cells were quite resistant to the DELTAC.
And then now moving on to in vivo studies with this compound.
We're looking at Yuanyuan Shao and
Gene Tien, we're really looking at two in vivo models, and in this particular
model, we're looking at castrated VCAP xenograft.
You can see a modest inhibition of
growth relative to the vehicle with just the bromodomain inhibitor and
the AR inhibitor. When we come in with the DELTAC orally,
we see further inhibition of growth.
When we come in with the DELTAC intraperitoneally, we can even see a nice tumor
regression in this very hard-to-treat castrated VCAP
model.We were able to show that ternary complex formation is actually
occurring in vivo between AR, DALTAC,
and the p300. And this is shown again by proximity ligation assay.
And perhaps this is probably the most exciting experiment
that we had from this series, was taking advantage of this metastatic
hormone-sensitive prostate cancer model.
We're comparing the DALTAC against vehicle.
These are the tumors growing here.
What was interesting was that all of the tumors regressed in the context of
this particular DALTAC. And when we took the
mice off of the DALTAC treatment, none of the tumors grew back.
So essentially, we were able to achieve
cures, at least in this particular mouse model.
And we've never really seen that using any type of even combination
treatment at least in the context of metastatic prostate cancer
models. And certainly,
this is just a slide suggesting that these compounds are not toxic, and one would
not expect them to be toxic when we look at body weight, CBC, and
various blood chemistry shown here.
So then just to wrap up in terms of
a general model, that this idea of reprogramming native
domain-domain interactions by these DALTACs, essentially sort of throwing a
molecular monkey wrench into essential assemblies such as the
AR p300 enhanceasome in general. And perhaps compared to
PROTACs,
DALTACs may offer some potential advantages.
You certainly don't need to engage the proteasomal
degradation machinery as an aspect, and they
essentially work faster than PROTACs.
So with that, I'd like to thank the individuals that
carried out these studies including Jia, as well as Jian
Zhang in Xiaoming Wang's lab, and our close collaboration with Xiaoming Wang's
group, a number of individuals in both of our groups
as well as the funding sources for this project.
Thank you for your interest and
we have time
for a few questions.
Hi, Arul. Fantastic talk. Jelani Zarif.
I had a question regarding
the mechanism. So just to clarify, it
glues it to
p300 using the N-terminal domain?
So
the heterobifunctional is binding to the bromodomain of
p300.
Okay.
So the histone acetyltransferase domain of p300 then sort of
swings back and hits the N-terminal domain of
AR-
Got you
... as part of that neomorphic interaction
that's created by the DALTAC.
I asked that question because the 22RV1 cells, as you know, have the
splice variant that doesn't have the LBD.
Right.
So most of your data was on VCAP. I was wondering if you had done it in
other xenografts that have
very high levels of the splice variant, et cetera.
We have done 22RV1 in vitro and in vivo, and they're quite sensitive
to the agents. I did show 22RV1,
and we're seeing similar effects in 22RV1, even in the context of
AR-V7.
Thank you.
Thank you. Excellent talk and excellent data.
The PDX model is very impressive that you can find a cure
for the prostate cancer. My question is, have you tried to do it in
a PDO model, which is enzalutamide resistant?
And what effect did you have?
Resistant to-- Well, we did use the castration-resistant
prostate cancer model. Again, that's the castrated VCAP model as
our model of resistance to AR-regulated
therapies. It has a massive amplification of AR in the context of
VCAP cells, and we did carry out that experiment in a castrated setting
perhaps most emulating patients with castration-resistant disease.
Yeah, I was more thinking about patient-derived organoid models, which
is enzalutamide resistant.
Ah.
Yeah. We have not done those experiments yet, but I would
just say that all of our AR-positive patient-derived
xenografts are quite sensitive to the DALTAC.
We have not yet
perhaps even generated enzalutamide-resistant
PDX organoids. But I think that that would be a good experiment to carry out.
Yeah. Thank you.
Miles.
Very interesting, Arul. So
you suggested that the AR sites are specifically the
oncogenic
targets. So have you looked at normal AR targets, seminal
vesicle or other androgen-dependent tissues in the mouse
to see whether you don't block a normal
AR function?
Yeah, that's a great question. We have not done that experiment yet,
but I think that that would be definitely worth doing and perhaps may even come up
in terms of formal tolerability and toxicity issues and so
forth.
Hey, Arul.
One last question.
Good talk. Two questions.
Did you look at the AR and p300 CVP levels across these cell
lines and kind of identify the threshold needed for this
activity?
Can you repeat that again?
The threshold of the AR and p300 and CBP protein
levels across your models.
Yeah. In general, the levels of AR and
p300 are
elevated. Certainly, we're using models where AR is often
amplified. We've also used models that have the splice variant,
models that have the mutation of AR.
So there's some variability in terms of AR expression.
In terms of p300, I would say it's perhaps at high levels, but not
necessarily
too elevated. I would say that it's really the N-terminal H2B marks that
are markedly elevated in AR-positive prostate cancer.
Okay, great. Thank you.
Great. I think we will now move on to our next speaker,
Dr. Johan de Bono, and I'll give you a brief introduction.
He is from The Royal Marsden and ICR.
He's an international leader in the development of transformative therapies for
advanced prostate cancer. As a clinical scientist, he has been at
the forefront of translating molecular insights into practice-changing clinical
trials, in particular, androgen receptor-targeted therapies and
PARP inhibitor therapies for HR-deficient prostate cancer.
I would say that his work has really reshaped, I would say, the therapeutic
landscape for patients with metastatic
disease and continues to define the future of prostate cancer
treatment.
Johan.
Thank you.
We stand on the shoulders of giants, and here's one of them.
I want to thank you for coming here today.
This is truly an exciting time, I think,
in developing new treatments for patients with prostate
cancer. And some of us are now developing this
mindset
of can we cure without castration?
Can we cure without AR blockade? So as you listen to my
talk, I want to be asking you to think about this because I think we
can start really planning clinical trials
that may be able to do that. I'm going to divide my talk into these
three sections. If you want to learn a bit more about some of this stuff, Misha and
I have published two reviews with a super fellow called Christina
Boscharou, who's worked in both our groups quite recently.
So background, I think it's fair to say that I remain
biased that most men who are dying of advanced
prostate cancer are primarily dying with AR positive
disease. And that bias is because I've been bob seeing really hundreds,
if not more than a thousand men with CRPC, and
my pathologist keeps coming back to me saying, "I can't find neuroendocrine
disease." I have also run trials for NEPC,
and it's not as common as I was thinking would be.
Now, that may be just my population of patients, but I really think
that targeting AR signaling remains arguably,
still, the most important thing to think about for this
disease. But there are, of course, other targets.
There's Akt phosphorylation, where I think we have really so
far been disappointed. I strongly believe in this
concept of chronic inflammatory cytokine release
fueling resistance and this concept that you heard about
beautifully from Dr. Charles Sawyers, one of the other giants in the field,
really, who presented on neuroendocrine plasticity
and this lineage switch that seems so
important perhaps in resistance modulation.
But certainly from where I sit, continued AR signaling remains important.
But I think it's fair to say that the drugs targeting the
AR ligand binding domain so far have been somewhat perhaps
disappointing, particularly the AR degraders.
There were some interesting talks at this meeting suggesting that the AR targeting
drugs don't necessarily remove AR and perhaps
freeze AR in an inactive state, which I found
quite interesting, these AR glues.
And please go and listen to those talks if you haven't heard them.
But here's the BMS AR degrader, probably the best compound
out there, really, that we've seen with some interesting anti-tumor activity.
Although I would worry that this compound in a phase three trial will
require some patient selection. And these drugs have had
most activity in AR mutated disease, which
we have shown and recently published in JCI, has
lower AR splice variants.
But what I got excited about, about four years ago when I met Craig Cruse's
team and the small biotech that he had just formed at this time
called Halda. And I started helping Halda develop their phase one
trial and planning this trial with this heterobifunctional
molecule targeting BRD4 and AR.
Now, the concept here is exactly as Arul was saying, is throwing in a monkey
wrench. I kind of think about it as gluing
the cogs of a Swiss watch. As the watch is
trying to move the hands of the watch, you're really gluing
wheels of that watch together, cogs together.
And here you've got this Riptac compound gluing AR
and
the BRD4 together. This compound can also impact BRD2 and
BRD3, I should also say.
And what I was impressed about when I first spoke to the Halda team
originally was they were seeing regressions in
established models, including models, as somebody mentioned
earlier, that are AR splice variant and AR targeted
therapy resistant. So really pre-clinically, this
looked pretty good.
So I helped design this phase one trial with someone called Ron Weitzman, who was
actually helping Halda out at the time.
They were fairly small at the time. I think some of the Halda team are here.
And we designed this phase one to phase two trial with a rapid dose
escalation. And really literally within months, we were starting to see
quite impressive anti-tumor activity in the clinic with
both PSA falls and resist responses.
Now, these are data from a few months ago, so they're not the most up-to-date data.
They're the data that are most recently in the public domain.
But this is the patient population.
You can see these men have had a lot of prior therapy,
typically prior taxanes, prior RPs, even a lot of the men prior
to teaching PSMA.The drug has not reached
MTD, and it's actually been very well tolerated.
And what amazed me, for a drug of 900 to 1,000 Dalton in size,
very well-absorbed. So the rules, Lipinski rules, are
perhaps not rules after all.
There's been some nausea, anemia, and fatigue, but generally, really a very
well-tolerated compound. And this drug is not trying to block AR
signaling. It's really trying to put, as Arul
said, a monkey wrench in the machinery.
The PK was really good. We see nice
dose-dependent increases in exposure in both the
Cmax and the AUC. And we're
seeing that with higher doses, we get
more exposures,
Tmax at 46 hours, and achieving steady state
within a few days of starting therapy.
And these are the initial data, and there's a lot more data now that I can share
with you today, but really quite impressive anti-tumor activity with a
drug that is not designed to block AR.
And now the question for me is, and you saw some of this from Arul,
if you give this drug to a man that's not castrate, that
has lots of DHT in the background, will you
see the same kind of anti-tumor activity in the absence of
AR blockade and tumor kill by doing this?
And I'm very confident actually, that we will.
And you'll see here some of the resist responses that we're seeing in
these men,
and
some of these are really durable responses.
Here, more patients with liver mets, for example, a baseline scan on
top.
Really quite impressive anti-tumor activity.
Here's another patient with a prostatic mass, large prostatic mass.
Very often the prostate is a sanctuary site.
And if you're a clinician treating these patients, you know what I'm talking about.
The patients often responds everywhere else, and they don't respond in the
prostate. And I really like seeing these prostatic lesions
regressing because that tells me the drug is getting into this
area that can be a sanctuary site. The trial was still ongoing.
It's still ongoing today. I'm sure this drug will go to Phase II in the near
future. This drug was acquired by Janssen about two months ago,
and we look forward to driving the Phase III trials for this agent that I
hope will show anti-tumor activity without blocking AR, and maybe can really
truly give us
impact without castration, which is really something I dream about.
The second really major area that we're really seeing a lot of activity
with is cell surface protein targeting drugs.
And I have to humbly admit that 20 or 25 years
ago, I did not really dream that immunotherapy would ever impact
this disease, an immune-cold disease.
But I want to say to you that really, we are seeing stunning anti-tumor activity,
particularly as I shared at GU ASCO with these dual-masked
PSMA CD3 engagers, but also with targeting STEAP1,
KLK2, and other targets. And you may have heard about some of the STEAP2
drugs from AstraZeneca at this meeting.
There are many different, I guess, constructs being generated for
this concept.
And the main things to think about is can we improve drug
disposition? Can we get a long enough half-life?
And people have, for example, pursued
albumin binding. They've changed the construct somewhat.
Can we decrease anti-drug antibodies that are neutralizing?
That's been an issue, for example, with the harpoon antibody that I helped
develop against PSMA CD3 and albumin, and the more complex
constructs can have more neutralizing antibodies.
Can we mask or can we decrease the CRS by
masking the antigen binding sites?
And I think now we can. And there's actually now also
engagers that are engaging NK cells, not just T cells.
And so these are some of the targets we're focusing on in prostate cancer.
I could have added Trop-2 here, but there's several of these ongoing.
And with the masked construct here, what we're seeing is really a cover
around the antibody that prevents
binding, which is removed in the tumor microenvironment.
So these are data presented by Kevin Kelly, at ASCO, now published with a
STEAP1 CD3. Really impressive activity.
Some is quite durable in some patients.
But you can start seeing 90% PSA fall in men with really
heavily pre-treated disease. These are some of the responses in liver
mets. You see really outstanding regression of disease.
This is the Janssen KLK2 CD3. Data a bit more preliminary there,
but now heading into Phase III trial with pazritumab, with really
exciting combination studies now also ongoing.
And I want to share with you data that I've led on the PSMA CD3 with dual
masking from Vir,
recently acquired by Sanofi. And this, for example, is one of my patients.
And I never thought in a man with multiple liver mets,
extensive bone mets, that within nine weeks, a
PSMA CD3 engager would essentially cause a complete
response. The PSA goes from 99.5,
well, maybe not a CR, but almost a CR.
Really impressive responses in this trial.
And what you see in this trial is that a third of patients almost have a
99% PSA fall, 50% have a 90% PSA
fall, and 80% have a 50% PSA fall. This is a
highly active molecule. We're able to push the dose high with this
antibody binding PSMA and CD3, minimizing
CRS with this masking. And this is the anti-tumor activity at all
dose levels. You can see here multiple dose levels.
And this is at dose levels above 3,000 micrograms per kilogram three
weekly. We initially started with a weekly schedule, then went to a three weekly
schedule. And you see a lot of patients having deep regressions
here with this drug, including regressions of really
extensive, for example, liver disease in this patient, PSA 403 down to
44, and 94% PSA fall.And
regressing lymph nodes, a PR by resist.
Here's another patient, it's another one of my patients.
Again, a major fall in PSA by 99%. Serial biopsies increased
CD3 T cells into this tumor,
CD3 cells into this tumor after therapy in this serial biopsy.
And a significant change in tumor cellularity.
So really, this is coming our way. I think immunotherapy is going to come and
change prostate cancer care. And again, this may be something we can
give without castration in these men.
And indeed, our data would indicate these drugs are likely to work a lot
more in untreated subjects that have not had
AR blockade, because AR blockade really enhances myeloid infiltration into
these tumors, causing significant myeloid
T cell suppression in these tumors.
The other area of really interest is radiopharmaceuticals.
Very briefly, work from many people, including many in this group.
Looking at targeting the tumor with beta particles or
alpha particles or both. A lot of work going on in this space.
There are a number of questions for me, and we've been doing trials with both small
molecules and antibodies with actinium targeting
radiopharmaceuticals. And the question is, which is going to be better?
And that's not clear to me as yet. But what I can tell you is that these
drugs work. This is a trial I've led, and Fred Saad presented this
at GU ASCO. And again, you can see a high response rate in
men with late-stage disease, with a lot of patients having a more
than 90% PSA fall in this
population of patients.
And this is
across all PSMA PET SUVs,
really activity across all levels with this actinium
PSMA radionuclide. This is the small molecule, not the antibody,
although we've also been running an antibody study with the same company, Bayer.
And you can see these beautiful scans.
Again, you can see really pretty much
stunning responses in these scans with these patients.
This is one of my patients, PSA falling by more than 90%.
This is a second patient here. And this has been seen by others, so I can't
claim that we've led on this, but it's so good to see
our patients benefiting. Although these drugs do have toxicities,
xerostomia particularly, lymphopenia as well, which
may mean that actually we should give these drugs perhaps at a time when
the immunotherapies have already been given to
minimize the impact on immunotherapy and tumor activity.
We also have antibody drug conjugates coming along.
Some are hitting just one tumor antigen, some are hitting two, that are
really showing impressive anti-tumor activity, targeting things like
B7-H3, STEAP1, even PSMA.
Some are even hitting two tumor-associated antigens at the same time,
maybe increasing tolerability. Some are hitting STEAP2.
So watch this space. I think payload is key for these
drugs, and we're now developing a new ADC with a senolytic
payload. This is going to be really quite interesting because we have
shown that with the Topo1 payloads, you have surviving resistant tumor
cells that are in senescence and inducing this myeloid
response. And you can look at our paper on the B7-H3 ADC for more on
that if you wish. And we have confirmed these drugs have anti-tumor activity in the
clinic and really quite impressive responses.
So in conclusion,
this is really, I think, certainly in my lifetime, a golden
age in prostate cancer drug development.
I envision we can start really thinking about curing advanced disease.
That might seem an exaggeration, but I've never seen drugs with such
deep responses. We have many new exciting therapeutic strategies under
evaluation. Smart combinations, ADCs with T-cell
engagers, for example.
I think there's going to be many new approvals over the next five to 10 years, and
the question is positioning, patient selection,
minimizing risk of late failure because designing the wrong trials.
And there has to be a lot of deep thought about this because the risk of failure
may not be as high before as it is now
because of all that's going on. I think cross-resistance with DNA-targeting
drugs particularly remains a concern.
Morbidity and patient-reported outcomes is key and must be
considered for all these trials, as must biomarker trials,
and sequencing is required. So acknowledge the patients and their
families, my teams, my many collaborators.
I'm very privileged to work with amazing people.
Our funders, including these people here, PCF, PCUK,
CRUK, and others, and many industry colleagues. Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Johan. We have time for some questions.
Thank you very much. Alistair Lamb, London.
Johan, thanks for a super talk. I just wonder if, do we need
to be careful about using the term cure?
I think even in localized prostate cancer, which I treat,
we're sort of stopping using that terminology.
In diabetes, people are okay with the fact that we're
controlling a disease. We don't have to aim for
cure. It's just interesting to hear somebody who manages advanced disease using
that terminology.
So I have patients in my clinic who
had widespread metastatic mismatch repair-defective
prostate cancer.
I treated them 10 years ago with pembrolizumab.
They're still coming to my clinic every six months.
They are still in CR, 10 years out from metastatic disease.
Asymptomatic, nothing on any scan I can find.
Now, I agree with you, we should be cautious, but we can at least dream.
I think dreaming of cure today is not unreasonable.
We have amazing understanding of biology.
I think if we do this right, we can haveThat thing,
that dream to pursue. And if anything's going to do it, in my
opinion, I think immunotherapy will do it.
I really think those MMR patients we have cured, but we'll have
to see. 10 years out, is that cured? Maybe not.
Breast cancer can come back after 20 years. But, let's see.
Thanks.
Hi, Johan. Fantastic talk as always.
I was curious, you showed a CD3
stain after the steep--
A CD3 positive stain after this-
Yes, MHC III, yeah.
Yeah. I was wondering if you see any other changes in antigen-presenting
cells that might traffic to those tumors.
I'm asking because Provenge is something that's
used to program dendritic cells to attack.
Yeah.
I was wondering if you see an influx in DCs or any-
So that work is still ongoing. And with Hyperplex,
immunofluorescence now is very feasible.
So yeah. I think one thing I would say is I'm very convinced that the
myeloid compartment is really key in this disease.
And thinking about eradicating myeloid compartments with these T cell engagers
is something we really need to think deeply about, in my opinion.
Thank you.
Hi .
I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I'm short too, I understand.
Hi, I'm Amy Leslie from Stanford. So my question, and I'm glad
you're already hinting at it, was the SPP1 TAMs
as shown last year by Lawrence Fong.
And you can see that when you go from local to
metastatic castration resistant, that you have an increase in these
tumor-associated macrophages.
Yes, agree.
And I'm glad you touched upon that because one of the issues with the T cell
engagers is T cell exhaustion and maybe targeting it in a broader
sense. And so I wanted to kind of ask your
consideration, since you brought up cell surface targeting,
about looking at the sugars, about glycosylation
and targeting that in order to trigger and
shape the tumor immune microenvironment and your thoughts.
Not my expertise, to be honest. It sounds hard, but
I can't speak with any kind of deep knowledge of this.
But yeah, it might be something we should pursue.
That "Nature" paper, SPP1 macrophage is something I know very well.
And I know Larry very well, so it's beautiful work.
There is emerging data from someone I work closely with called Marco Bezzi
that seems to indicate that certain genomic backgrounds
result primarily in that macrophage infiltration.
And other genomic backgrounds primarily drive myeloid
infiltration. And I think this is something we really need to tease out.
So,
do think about that if you're working in that space. But Larry is amazing.
Thank you.
Thank you. Sorry, last
question.
Yeah.
Because I don't think enzalutamide is going anywhere,
despite it continuing to cause resistance.
And I like the idea of going without castration, but I
don't know if we're ever going to lose AR blockade.
So considering the giants that you were talking about, such as
the beloved Felix, I was wondering on that paper,
from 2025,
it's been shown that AR blockade increases MHC1 and T
cells. But on the same time, we don't want to have
enzalutamide because it kind of causes a tumor
immunosuppressive microenvironment.
And so to use or not to use enzalutamide,
how are we going to go forward?
So I'm just not sure about the AR blockade increasing T
cell MHC1 presentation. I'm just not sure about that data.
I think that came out of Portland, right? It was certainly part.
I don't know. Certainly, one big concern is not
minimize or not blocking T cell function in these tumors.
Although many of them may already have exhausted T cells before we start therapy,
so we'll have to see. We have to do trials and
pursue this. We did trials with MSD, with pembro, and
enzalutamide to try and pursue that question.
Nothing changed. So, I don't know.
So that's the answer to your question. I just don't know.
But we need to think about this. But thank you.
Hi, great presentation. Ace from Vancouver Process Center.
I do have a question regarding that, as you mentioned, you
talk about how not having a castration to be the first,
potential therapy option. However, for the first drug that you
mentioned, the majority of your
patients selected are CRPC. I'm just wondering, have you,
using the drug on the metastatic hormonal sensitive?
So that's the plan. And in fact, that's what I was alluding to,
that these heterobifunctional molecules, that they can outcompete
testosterone, and I am confident they will.
And in fact, Aru showed that his compound can.
Maybe we could impact these tumor cells and kill them
without
blocking your function. And we'll have to see.
I don't know if that's going to be possible, but that would be a wonderful thing.
All right. Thanks.
Great talk, Johan. So you've done obviously great work on the
BRCA2 space and the role of PARP inhibitors.
So have you explored, or do you have any feeling about
whether PARP inhibitor treatment alters the immune microenvironment
in a way that might alter the efficacy of the T cell engagers or the other
immunotherapy approaches?
So yeah, we have a paper under review, Miles, and we're going to present it again
next week in Lugano, that actually,
basically, PARP inhibition clears the myeloid compartment.
And that there's primitive myeloid cells in these tumors that are proliferating,
and have very high PARP-1 expression.
And, PARP inhibition essentially eradicates the myeloid cells
So watch this space.
Oh, sorry.
We need to move on.
Yeah, we need to move on. Thank you.
So it's a pleasure to introduce our last speaker of this session, Misha
Beltran of the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute, a leader in
the molecular dissection of advanced prostate cancer in general.
Also a physician scientist, her work has been instrumental in defining lineage
plasticity and neuroendocrine transformation,
reshaping how we understand resistance to androgen receptor-targeted
therapies. She's well-known for the Beltran
NEPC, or neuroendocrine prostate cancer, data set that many groups utilize,
including our own,
in terms of the study of neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
Through elegant translational studies, she continues to bridge genomics
and clinical insight to inform the next generation of precision therapies.
Misha.
Thank you. It's such an honor to be here,
especially with Dr. Schnall and De Bono, as I've greatly admired them throughout my
career. I was really lucky very early on in my career to get to work
with them as part of the International Standard Prostate Cancer, PCF
Dream Team, which was a tremendous opportunity for me at an early
and formative era of my work. So today, I'll
be talking about therapeutic advances in neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
Here are my disclosures. But before I do that, I think it's helpful to step back
and reflect on what Dr. De Bono just presented and how exciting it is in
drug development in prostate cancer,
drugs targeting the cell surface, better ways to target the androgen receptor, and
potentially other transcription factors targeting the epigenome.
And ultimately, as these drugs move through clinical development, patient selection
will be important, especially as we start thinking about rational combination
strategies. And overall, this represents a shift from targeting
genotype to targeting phenotype.
And one very important phenotype in prostate cancer is a small
cell neuroendocrine phenotype, and it's not the most common type of prostate
cancer. But it is important to recognize because this can arise later
during the disease as a mechanism of resistance and can be very aggressive,
and work by our group and many others over the last decade have really tried to
delineate some of the molecular mechanisms that underlie this
phenotypic switch, this lineage reprogramming that it can occur
in advanced prostate cancer. And from a therapeutic perspective, it's
important as lineage plasticity can alter the surfazome.
So this has important implications for drugs that are currently in
development, but also a way for us to exploit this change in cell
surface therapeutically to target acquired antigens
that might occur with the neuroendocrine phenotype and potentially other
phenotypes as well.
When you look at the therapeutic landscape of neuroendocrine prostate cancer over
the years and currently in clinical development, here's a short
list. Many of these drugs are targeting DLL3,
delta-like ligand 3, as this is a cell surface protein expressed in
small cell lung cancer, other small cell carcinomas, and we showed several
years ago now that it's enriched in small cell neuroendocrine
prostate cancer, quite specific for a neuroendocrine phenotype.
This is work led by Laura Donadруппа in our lab at that time.
And delta-like protein 3 is part of the Notch pathway.
And it's a Notch inhibitory ligand, and work by
Shengjie Ku in our lab from a mechanistic point of view has
reported how while the Notch pathway can be oncogenic in
early prostate cancer, the entire pathway is shut down or turned
down-regulated when tumors switch to a neuroendocrine prostate cancer and
becomes tumor suppressive. And this down-regulation
of Notch is associated with up-regulation of the DLL3
and ASCL1, also a Notch inhibitory ligand.
And
loss of Notch is really important for maintaining a neuroendocrine
phenotype.
So there's lots of different ways to target DLL3.
We've been working with gocatumig, which is a T cell engager that binds
DLL3, CD3, and albumin to redirect T cells.
And we see potent preclinical activity when we treat PDX models with
human T cells and gocatumig with infiltration of
T cells in treated tumors. And interestingly, we also saw
pretty profound effects even in mixed tumors, those with mixed
neuroendocrine histology. And through a series of mixing
experiments, co-culturing,
RFP and GFP tag cells that are DLL3 negative or DLL3
overexpressing, we see that actually there was
cellular impact of the drug even in DLL3 negative
cells, suggesting a potential bystander effect.
And I think the bystander effect is really important when thinking about
neuroendocrine prostate cancer, when we often see a lot of heterogeneity.
We presented interim results of an ongoing Phase I/II clinical trial
of gocatumig at ESMO last year. This is a pan-neuroendocrine
carcinoma trial where response rates were approaching 50%,
disease control rate 72%, shown in the red box.
There's a dose that's moving forward for further expansion.
And I would say that for this very heavily pre-treated, very aggressive
subtypes of cancers, this is a promising signal.
When we look at the neuroendocrine prostate cancer patients treated on that trial,
shown here are the first 20 patients where we looked at their
tumors, there was not a strong association between
the levels of DLL3 expression and response, which was
surprising
given the fact that that's not been seen in the case of small cell lung cancer, or
shown here small cell bladder cancer, suggesting that maybe there is more
heterogeneity in prostate cancer, and biomarkers may be different in the context
of NEPC compared to other small cell.Indeed, we do
see heterogeneity of DLL3 intra-tumorally and
inter-tumorally in patients, and there's a strong correlation
between DLL3 and ASCL1. So ASCL1
represents a subtype of small cell carcinomas, and
this may contribute in part to the
subtype-specific DLL3 expression that may be reflected also with
NeuroD1 and other potential small cell subtypes that we can see
within this context. Indeed, when we knock out NeuroD1 in neuroendocrine
prostate cancer models, we don't see any change in DLL3.
But when we knock out ASCL1, we see strong downregulation of
DLL3.
And when we look at patients that are treated with gocatumig, shown here is a
patient where we see we have progressing-- a patient that
responded and then developed acquired resistance, where we see overall lower levels
of antigen suggesting a potential acquired resistance mechanism.
And potentially, these are still neuroendocrine and may be due to subtype
switching, something that's also emerging in small cell lung cancer.
So the heterogeneity that we see in prostate cancer, particularly when it comes
to neuroendocrine prostate cancer, as well as what we see
post-treatment, does speak to the potential need for
better imaging modalities to capture heterogeneity.
And Michael Morris and Jason Lewis from Memorial have nicely
shown in examples of how DLL3 PET imaging may
complement PSMA PET imaging to detect neuroendocrine prostate
cancer and is more specific than
FDG PET. So thinking about how do we detect neuroendocrine
prostate cancer, and also how can we develop biomarkers to predict
response to DLL3-targeted agents will be important.
And I think also, given all this heterogeneity we see in prostate cancer,
there's also strong rationale to think about co-targeting more than
one cell surface protein in this context.
And so we've been trying to learn more about the heterogeneity of
cell surface target expression in work led by Martin Vock in our lab.
We've assembled a cohort, which we term SHAPE, where we're
collecting PET images, histology, IHC, genomics,
and performing spatial transcriptomics using the Visium 10X
genomics platform.
And this is still ongoing work, but we've collected a
nice cohort of tumors
of biopsies and autopsy specimens, and many of them have had
prior treatment with lutetium PSMA 617.
And again, we're really focused on this neuroendocrine phenotype as well.
Looking at some of our first patients, at the first 175,000
spots from our first 26 patients, we can see the
transcriptomic data using graph-based clustering can
distinguish adenocarcinoma from neuroendocrine prostate cancer, which were
confirmed by histology. And then you can start to see these clusters with
PSMA and DLL3, where we
often see mutual exclusivity, but you can start to identify clusters that
might have co-expression of PSMA and DLL3.
And overall, of the NEPC clusters,
86% expressed a DLL3, I think providing further
confirmation of this as a robust biomarker.
We've started to characterize patients as they develop neuroendocrine prostate
cancer. Here's a patient that had CRPC
adenocarcinoma that developed mixed tumor and then neuroendocrine prostate
cancer, and through pseudo-time analysis of the transcriptomic data,
could predict that loss of PSMA preceded the gain of
DLL3. And we can then layer on adeno and neuroendocrine
markers to this transcriptomic data, and then also other cell
surface targets to see dynamic changes.
And in this case, PSMA
went down, Trop-2 went down, STEAP1 went
down, DLL3
became overexpressed, and B7H3 was
strongly expressed in an adeno mixed in NEPC, another
important target. So I think understanding
dynamic changes through serial time points may be informative.
We've also been interested in using these data to understand the metastatic
niche, and we have previously reported using bulk RNA
sequencing data that PSMA is
often suppressed or lower and more heterogeneous in liver
metastasis. And here you can see a rapid autopsy case where we had
multiple sites of metastasis, and using this transcriptomic data, the
prostate tumor, so this is a CRPC at autopsy, is distinguished from the
liver mets from the normal liver.
And in this case, androgen receptor was strongly expressed in the liver
despite low PSMA expression, and we can
understand that the prostate gave rise to these very heterogeneous liver
metastasis in this individual. And when we looked
at what are the pathways that are changing or
different in these PSMA-suppressed liver mets, we
see a lot of metabolic pathways coming up, including we were
interested in amino acid biosynthesis, as we see
AST2 amino acid transporter highly expressed in this context,
something that we had seen previously in our prior work looking at neuroendocrine
prostate cancer when thinking about exploiting amino acid
uptake using fluciclovine PET imaging, where we see
strong fluciclovine PET signal in preclinical PDX models as
opposed to PSMA PET. And this work led to a clinical
trial, a pilot study that we're doing in collaboration with Heather Jacene from
Nuclear Medicine at Dana-Farber, where we're performing both PSMA PET
and fluciclovine PET in patients with PSMA-low disease based on
SUV means or neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
And this is still ongoing, but I'll say it's really interesting so far in
understanding how fluciclovine is capturing areas not captured
by PSMA, but also not captured by FDG PET.
And really trying to understand the metabolic features at the tissue level,
looking at biopsies from these patients will be really important to understand
not just their tissue correlates when it comes to PSMA and LAT1 or other amino
acid transporters, but also other potential transcriptional and
genomic
correlates.So PSMA is regulated in
part by the androgen receptor, binding its upstream enhancer,
interacting with cofactors. So in tumors that lose the
androgen receptor, like neuroendocrine prostate cancer, we do expect low
PSMA.
We can also sometimes see low PSMA despite high AR,
like I showed in that liver met, due to methylation or other
potential mechanisms that lead to PSMA suppression.
In addition to understanding how antigen regulation
impacts resistance to DLL3, we've also been thinking about this in the context of
lutetium PSMA-617. So I mentioned many of our
patients in our cohort had prior exposure, and we found that most of
these tumors still retained PSMA expression at the
transcriptomic or/and protein level.
But we do see some cases where you see a lot more heterogeneity in
PSMA expression at the time of resistance.
This is a patient who got lutetium PSMA-617,
ended up dying from his disease, where we did-- Had a post-treatment
PET, and ended up dying from his disease where we did PET-directed tissue
sampling,
where we're trying to understand both PET signal
attenuating regions and PET signal enhancing regions.
And even the PET attenuating regions had very high
Ki-67, other metabolic markers, proliferation markers.
So PET signal in itself may not
always represent treated responding disease.
In this case, where we had 42 post-lutetium tumors,
19% of these tumors had evidence of
neuroendocrine or mixed tumors at resistance, which presumably
was not suspected before getting a lutetium PSMA, given the inclusion
criteria. 81% did not have neuroendocrine features.
So the neuroendocrine all had PET attenuating lesions.
The non-neuroendocrine could have had attenuating or enhancing
lesions. And so trying to understand the mechanisms underlying this
is area that we're investigating further.
So a lot of what I've talked about so far has been talking about neuroendocrine
prostate cancer. What about targeting plasticity itself?
And you heard already from the prior talks about new and exciting ways to
potentially target transcription factors that may be driving
lineage reprogramming. We've also been thinking about how to target the
epigenome, as there are a number of drugs that have been developed
to target the epigenetic
pathways.
Arul Chinnaiyan was the first to show that EZH2 is upregulated in
advanced prostate cancer, and we had shown also further
upregulated in the context of neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
And this is associated with downregulation of
EZH2-repressed target genes.
So EZH2 is part of the PRC2 complex that plays a very
important role in normal development through deposition of H3K27
trimethylation, resulting in transcriptional silencing.
PRC2 activity also plays an important role for cancer
initiation and has also been implicated in lineage
plasticity in prostate cancer.
EZH2 also has a non-canonical function, can activate genes, as Miles Brown
has shown in the context of androgen receptor, and can also interact with other
transcription factors to drive
different cellular identity programs.
And there's
recent data from the MAVRO-MEDISAT enzalutamide trial, an early phase
trial that looked at patients post abiraterone and showed a
very strong RPFS benefit of the combination of an EZH2
inhibitor plus enzalutamide compared to enzalutamide alone with a hazard ratio
of 0.51, and this combination has now moved to phase
three clinical trials. And as we see more data, I think it'll be really
important to understand how is this working and who are the patients most
likely to benefit from this combination.
Is it going to be AR-driven tumors, lineage plasticity tumors, neuroendocrine
tumors? And as we start thinking about genomic, epigenomic, and potentially
transcriptomic biomarkers.
We were surprised that in our preclinical models of neuroendocrine prostate
cancer, we did not see
great activity of EZH2 inhibition.
Despite downregulation of H3K27 trimethylation, we did not
see upregulation of AR or sensitization to
enzalutamide in this context.
So Balaji in our lab hypothesized that, well, maybe PRC2 has
different targets in the context of adenocarcinoma versus
neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
And indeed, when we look at genome-wide H3K27 trimethylation, we do
see differences between CRPC adenocarcinoma and neuroendocrine
prostate cancer. When we look at what's enriched in adenno,
we see H3K27 trimethylation enrichment
on neuronal genes and neurogenesis programs, suggesting that
they may be repressed in adenno
by H3K27 trimethylation and potentially
de-repressed during the
progression to neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
He looked at what genes are preferentially regulated in the context of EZH2
inhibition in CRPC versus NEPC.
Shown here are two models where we look at those genes that are
preferentially upregulated, many of which were marked by
bivalency, harboring both activated and repressive
marks, including MHC class one genes that were immediate targets of
EZH2 inhibition, upregulated, something that has been seen in other
contexts as well.
When we look at genes marked by bivalency that were
upregulated after EZH2 inhibition in neuroendocrine prostate cancer,
near the top of the list were neurogenesis, neuronal transcription factors, even
ASCL1, that were upregulated. And we saw this across multiple
models. We saw this after CRISPR silencing of EZH2.
So instead of going backwards, it seems as if the neuroendocrine tumors
were becoming even more neuroendocrine.
Maybe we're pushing the tumors forward for forward differentiation to a more
terminal state, and this may be exploitable therapeutically as
well.And this is also consistent with a recent paper by David Goodrich,
who has showed that EZH2 acts as a constraint on lineage
state, and so potentially can explain why we
sometimes see this backward or forward differentiation in the
context of EZH2 inhibition. And so beyond
co-targeting EZH2 with the androgen receptor, maybe we can think more
carefully about combination approaches based on this
data.
EZH2 doesn't act alone. There's also
interactions and cooperation with other epigenetic machineries and in
development, lots of literature supporting the crosstalk between
PRC2 and DNA methyltransferase in the context of
EZH2 inhibitor resistance and hematologic
malignancies. DNA methylation can
be acquired in areas previously marked by H3K27
trimethylation, implying a resistance mechanism.
And we recently showed, in collaboration with David Rickman's lab at
Weill Cornell and Richa Singh, who presented these data at a mini symposium
yesterday at AACR, that there is crosstalk between
EZH2 and DNA methylation in neuroendocrine
prostate cancer and during lineage plasticity.
When you target DNMT, you can alter EZH2
activity, and loss of
EZH2, both in human models and mouse models, leads to changes in
DNA methylation. So really understanding how epigenetic programs
cooperate, I think, will be really important as we develop
more and newer effective ways to target
plasticity. So just to summarize, neuroendocrine
prostate cancer is an aggressive variant of prostate cancer that has important
therapeutic implications, particularly when we think about the cell surface
and all the drugs that are in development, and how to leverage this to target
new phenotypes that might emerge.
Epigenetic regulators play a key role, and understanding their
context-dependent activity will be important as we develop
combination approaches to target plasticity, differentiation,
and tumor heterogeneity.
So I just want to acknowledge my very talented lab for all their work,
multiple wonderful collaborators, and our funding sources.
Thank you for your attention.
Great work. Good to see you.
I was just wondering about
what do you think
DLL3 shedding
would be doing in the tumor microenvironment, or
if that would be a
mechanism of resistance in these tumors, or do you think it's not going to be an
issue with the
engagers?
Yeah, I think, we haven't done a lot of deep diving
into resistant tumors in patients.
We do have a preclinical model that we're developing that has acquired
resistance, where you do see lower levels of DLL3,
potentially due to
other subtypes that are driving this neuroendocrine-ness.
So loss of antigen may be an important mechanism.
DLL3, we did not see it to be a key driver in itself.
It's really a representation of the Notch pathway and potentially a readout of
ASCL1 activity as well. Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi, Misha. Great talk. I was wondering about the EZH2 data.
I found it really tantalizing, and I was wondering if you saw any changes
in B7H3 expression in those tumors that got
worse, and did you see any bone mets or liver mets in vivo?
Yeah. We do see a little bit of upregulation of B7H3.
We saw it more pronounced with our DNA methyltransferase inhibitors, and
we published a paper a couple of years ago
because neuroendocrine tends to have less
B7H3 expression. I think Johan has shown that relationship with AR and
how we could re-express B7H3 through DNA
methyltransferase inhibitors. We haven't seen that same correlation with
EZH2 inhibitors necessarily.
Thank you.
Xin Yao from UBC Canada. Well, what a nice talk, Dr.
Berletch. Well,
I'm
curious about how you showed the specific epigenetic
modulation from the adrenal to NEPC.
And my question is, during the process of cancer progression,
what did modulate the epigenetic modulation from
adrenal to the NEPC? What's the initiator
of the epigenetic regulation? Is it genetic
background or the AR targeted treatment, or what?
Yeah, so that's a great question. What comes first?
And we see dysregulation of the epigenome.
We also see activation of alternative transcription factors.
All of this happens in the face of therapeutic pressure.
And so I don't think I have a great
understanding as to even when AR is lost in this whole
process. But I think that it's really
the change in the lineage drivers that are likely
reprogramming the epigenome. And so I think some of the work in targeting the
transcription factors and how that also impacts the
consequence-- what's the chicken and the egg question.
But I think that it's likely due to a lot of the transcription factor
dysregulation.
Thank you.
So we still have 10 minutes, so if anyone else has any questions for either
Misha, Johan, or myself, this would be your opportunity.
Misha, can I ask a question? One of the things we're discussing, writing a paper
on neuroendocrine with Emmanuel,
is what proportion of these tumors actually have RB loss and
53 alteration from the outset? And what
proportion
acquired that as a new alteration during therapy?Do you
have a kind of sense of that? Is there just rare RB
loss cells there from the beginning in most of these subjects, or that kind of
emerge as the predominant clone, you think in many,
or?
I think that
there are higher risk hormone-naive tumor
cells that
maybe have het loss that we're underappreciating of RB,
or P53 that are more prone to plasticity,
rather than becoming full-blown neuroendocrine necessarily.
But we've seen this even in neoadjuvant studies, that if you look at that
population, that there may be an opportunity to think about that.
I think RB is universally lost in neuroendocrine, but we don't always see it at the
genomic level. And so probably we're miss--
Because I can't imagine compared to other small cell carcinomas where it's
universally lost, that we're not seeing it in prostate.
So I think RB plays a really critical role, and it's not
in itself the only thing. We need other things to kind of hit on top of that.
One thing that I keep thinking about is why RB?
Why do the cells lose RB? Are they using it a lot before it's
lost? I'm pretty obsessed about
senescence. So you wonder, are they kind of
hyper-activating RB so that it's exposed and then getting damaged?
Why are they losing RB so much? Do you have a sense of that?
I think RB has a multifaceted function beyond cell cycle and
differentiation, and so there may be other functions besides
just that are really important for the plasticity.
Yeah. Thank you.
I might have a question related to Johan's there for you, Misha.
As you know, in AR positive adenocarcinoma, there are clear
molecular subtypes of prostate cancer in terms of being
ETS fusion positive, FOXA1 positive, SPOP, and so forth.
What are your thoughts in terms of neuroendocrine prostate cancer?
Do you think that there are sort of decisive molecular subtypes of the
disease?
I think that,
as we see ETS fusions in neuroendocrine, we even saw that in de novo small
cell prostate, so suggesting the same cell of origin.
But yeah, obviously we lose ERG,
but where you have the fusion, I don't know if SPOP would be
protective.
DNA repair, I think we see similar frequencies in neuroendocrine versus
adenno in late stage. But I think this tumor
suppressor loss, and I think even though not always
neuroendocrine maybe,
we do see enrichment, so maybe that's something along, even from the get go.
Yeah. My general thought was that in neuroendocrine prostate cancer, really the
ETS fusions don't make a difference.
FOXA1 probably doesn't make a difference, and SPOP doesn't make a
difference. It's really other-
Right
... part of the dedifferentiation process, and other things take over, potentially.
They could've been there early, and maybe loss-
Yes
... of ERG-
That's right
... is important for the dedifferentiation.
Right. For sure.
Miles?
Hello. I enjoyed all the talks. My name is Efram.
I'm from University at Buffalo. My question is, I guess to all of
you on the panel.
So I know, Dr. Shenayan,
there was
previous work from your lab about SWI/SNF and
involvement with neoenhancersomes with AR.
And as we see, AR is lost in neuroendocrine prostate
cancer. Do you think that there could be some sort of
maybe a rearranging of those neoenhancersomes where AR is
lost, and where maybe SWI/SNF or other
chromatin remodelers are now working with other
drivers such as EZH2 or FOXA1?
That's a great question. We've certainly evaluated SWI/SNF
antagonists in both AR positive disease as well as AR
negative disease, and that being neuroendocrine, perhaps
encompassing much of AR negative or AR indifferent disease.
And at least in our assessments, AR negative
disease or neuroendocrine prostate cancers tend not to be sensitive
to SWI/SNF. But they could certainly be dependent
on other oncogenic transcription factors that perhaps use other
nucleosomal remodeling factors for function, essentially.
So that's sort of our general working hypothesis, I would say.
They certainly are not sensitive to SWI/SNF antagonists.
Thank you.
Ro, in terms of your AR DELTAC, have you tried it in cell
lines or models that are AR expressing but not AR
dependent, or in fact, even AR suppressor?
For example, in T47D breast cancer cells, they're quite AR
positive, but androgens are actually suppressive.
But do you get a dominant effect of the AR DELTAC in inhibiting their growth?
Yeah, that's a great question. That was one of the first things that we did, was
look at other AR positive cell line systems, including
AR positive triple negative
cell lines. And what's interesting is that we found that
they're actually not sensitive to the AR based
DELTACs. And so our thought there is that
those cell lines or lineages need to be
dependent on both AR and p300 to
have sensitivity, which AR positive prostate cancer indeed is.
But AR positive triple negative breast
cancer appears not to be as sensitive to
perhaps AR antagonism and p300
inhibition.
Did you try T47Ds in that-
We did. They're not sensitive.
So an AR positive, AR suppressed.
That's right. We have tried that specific cell line, and my recollection is that
they're not sensitive at all to the AR DELTAC.
On that note, can I ask you, is the drug trapped on DNA?
Does the drug trap the complex on DNA?
We haven't looked
at the drug specifically, but I would believe that that would be the case, because
certainly AR and p300 are trapped on
chromatin.And presumably on DNA, and so the drug is
there along with the complex-
So I guess like PARP, could it cause double-strand breaks?
That's a great question, and we're trying to investigate that. Yeah, exactly.
Hi, Alex Herd. Great talks. I have a question related to the
emerging bifunctionals, these hold-and-trap mechanisms, and how you think about
stoichiometry between AR and the other protein,
particularly given your warhead is presumably inducing the feedback loop, and it's
actively changing the levels of AR.
Yeah.
I think what we're seeing, interestingly enough, is that
the warhead is essentially recruiting
dimerized or translocated AR2 chromatin.
And so essentially actually pulling it out of the cytoplasm, and that's what it
looks like in terms of not only increased stabilization of AR,
but you're essentially trapping AR in
the nucleus and out of the cytosol and so forth.
So that's a combination of both stabilizing AR and
perhaps increasing its expression, but then
it's actually trapping AR
in the nucleus in that context.
So does that mean that you're not turning on the feedback loop in this case?
Correct. Yeah. That's right.
Thank you.
So with regards to the AR P300. So
do you see the loss of P300 in non-AR sites?
Because the idea would be like it's sequestered by AR, right?
So it most likely is lost in the non-AR region.
We're seeing actually
P300 is being recruited away from its
endogenous sites and accumulating at AR sites essentially is what we're
seeing. And so it is getting pulled away from sites that it
might normally be utilized for, for perhaps working with other
transcription factors, and it's getting recruited to where AR is
in terms of the chromatin.
Okay. The next question is about the stoichiometry, right?
Mm-hmm.
If you take a line where you overexpress AR, do you make those
lines sensitive to your DELTAC? Because then it will be able to sequester the
rest of the P300.
Well, no, we don't. Those lines tend not to be sensitive to
blocking AR. So for example, if you overexpress it in a 293
cell and come in with the DELTAC,
we don't see any sensitivity in that context.
And hi, this question is Beltran. And then could you please
provide more mechanistic insight about the increase in
H3K27 trimethylations? Is it really
associated with the increase EZH2 or something else?
Yeah,
we believe it's related to the EZH2 expression as a
readout, a functional readout of EZH2 catalytic activity.
Obviously, it doesn't capture the non-canonical activity.
So that's what I think is often measured in trials too to look at
on-target effect, and that's what we've been using as well.
And I think that's where we're seeing differential patterns in
the context of different subtypes of prostate cancer, where that deposition or
that transcriptional silencing is
from the PRC2 complex.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
This question is to Dr. Chalian.
What is the fate of the AR and the P300
after binding to the DELTAC? I know you mentioned that it
goes to the nucleus.
Long-term, what happens to the proteins?
We're certainly not seeing degradation of the
proteins, but in general, the cell itself
either is undergoing cell death or senescence and so forth, but
the proteins remain basically locked down on
chromatin for the most part.
We're certainly not seeing degradation of the targets.
Okay. So which means that for each DELTAC, it binds to one
molecule of the androgen receptor and one molecule of the
CBP, right?
Right. Or a dimer in the case of androgen receptor.
Yes. Okay. Thank you.
Hi, my question is for Dr. Belshan.
As you mentioned,
the expression of DLL3 is not consistent with the
efficacy of the target therapy.
I'm just wondering, have you compared the transcriptomic
profiles of those responding to the drug and not
responding to the drug, even though they are all both very
high DLL3 expressed?
Yeah, that's a great question. We haven't done much more yet as far as the
translational work on the trial, but that's something that we'll be doing.
Right. And also alluded to what Dr.
Sawyer talked about, how Notch signaling could be
suppressing any transdifferentiation.
Would you expect to see, although the DLL3 levels
are quite similar within those responders and non-responders,
would the Notch signaling levels could be different?
Yeah. I think DLL3 is a marker of,
in some ways, an indirect marker of Notch activity.
Right. All right. Thank you.
Just a quick, brief question. I think we need to end the session here pretty soon.
This is very brief. I just had a question about the AR P300
glue.
You showed that the
BRD4 and some other interactors were lost from
those sites following using the glue.
I was wondering if you used or perhaps performed a RIME to look at how
the AR interactome changes following using
that glue.
Yeah, that's a great question, and we're planning those experiments, but we haven't
actually carried that out in terms of a more comprehensive
assessment of the AR interactome in the context
of the DELTAC. But that's a great experiment-
Thank you
... that we're working on essentially.
Thank you.
Great. I think with that, I'd like to thank everyone for participating
and thank our speakers, both Misha and Johan.